what if Thor's funniest friends will
return for the Asgardian heroes next
cinematic venture during a recent
interview director Taika Waititi who
helmed the franchise Reviver thor
ragnarok and will also direct thor love
and thunder confirm the return of a fan
favorite character his name of course is
cork and he's coming back to the big
screen for more poor though his
conversation with Jimmy Kimmel was
mostly about his buzzy new film Joe Joe
rabbit ytt briefly touched on Thor love
and thunder which is when the director
made this exciting announcement my
characters coming back a member of an
ancient group of rock like humanoid
entities horde made his official debut
in Thor Ragnarok but he actually wasn't
the first cronin to appear in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe the MCU can in
details at a prominent member of the
Marauders the coalition of invaders that
attacked the nine realms including
Thor's homeworld of Asgard was a cronin
warrior that cronin tried to throw down
with Thor during the battle on vanaheim
in 2013's Thor the dark world but the
god of thunder took him down in 2017 s
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 2 Cronin's
were shown fighting when the quadrant
was past them many fans have speculated
that one of the two prone ins was Court
who wound up getting sent as a car and
was forced to compete in the Grand
Master's contest of Champions in Thor
Ragnarok Court meets Thor in a holding
area where the grandmasters champions
prepare to fight well I tried to start a
revolution but didn't print enough
pamphlets so hardly anyone tuned up
except for my mum and her boyfriend who
I hate the two quickly become allies and
Korg ultimately stages a mutiny against
the Grandmaster Korg escapes from Sekar
and pops up again to help defeat the
villainous hella on the Rainbow Bridge
leading into Asgard after the fiery
demon Surtur rises again it destroys
Asgard at the end of thor ragnarok Korg
sticks around with his godly buddy
though he didn't appear in Avengers
infinity war Korg emerged as a lucky
survivor of panels to snap and Avengers
endgame with half the universe's
population gone Korg and meek reunited
with four and lived together in new
Asgard for five years Korg provided
emotional supports as Thor struggled
with his feelings and Korg even lent a
hand in the final fights against Thanos
all this is to say that Korg has been an
important part of Thor's life for many
years and that's not going to change in
Thor
Thunder which will likely start off by
filling us in and what's happened since
we last saw Korg and poor embracing his
bigger body and knowing that he's still
worthy of being a hero
Thor joined forces with the guardians of
the galaxy in the final moments of
endgame when the Galaxy saving crew were
about to ship out in search of gomorrah
meanwhile Korg headed home to new Asgard
where Valkyrie is now king while we
can't speculate on what might happen in
the upcoming third guardians of the
galaxy movie which might see Thor in the
mix we can theorize that Thor love and
thunder will see Thor returning home to
new Asgard and having a happy reunion
with Korg and Valkyrie
ytt has confirmed that love and thunder
will introduce the MC use first openly
bisexual character and Valkyrie who will
be looking for her Queen in the new
movie it seems safe to assume that love
and thunder might see Korg serving as
one about Curry's royal advisors helping
her find a lucky lady to aid in ruling
new Asgard whichever way the cookie
crumbles Korg is sure to bring plenty of
laughs and some rocky shoulders to cry
on should anyone need them in the new
Thor flick the only bad news about for
love and thunder thus far however is
that fans will have to wait until
November 5th 2021 to see it until then
there's undoubtedly plenty of exciting
news to come for the god of thunder
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]